- [Narrator] Neanderthals
are often depicted
as brutish cave men, but science shows
that our early ancestors
were actually quite advanced.
Neanderthals, or homo neanderthalensis,
are our closest relatives
in the human family tree.
The species lived from about
400,000 to 40,000 years ago
and inhabited an area
that stretched as far was
as Europe's Atlantic coast and
as far east as central Asia.
Their habitat reached northward
to modern day Belgium,
making them the first
humans to survive a cold,
glacial ecosystem.
The north's cold environment
may have influenced
neanderthals' physique.
Their bodies were relatively short,
with males averaging
five feet, five inches
and females five feet, one inch tall,
and they were stocky with broad chests,
bulky torsos, and muscular limbs.
These adaptations helped neanderthals
generate and retain body heat.
Also, their noses were large
and had relatively high bridges.
This created a nasal chamber that warmed
and humidfied the cold, dry air
they'd breathe in northern regions.
Apart from adaptations
that helped neanderthals
survive a harsh, wintry habitat,
the species also developed large brains.
They were similar in size
to modern humans' brains
and were often larger.
An increase in brain size may have played
a significant role in another
type of adaptation, culture.
Culture is indicative of
an intelligent species,
and archeological evidence suggests
that neanderthals had a
relatively sophisticated culture.
They built shelters,
made and wore clothing,
and created advanced tools.
In fact, they were the first human species
to make tools out of bone, not just stone.
They also created objects that
served ornamental purposes.
Neanderthals are suspected
to be the first humans
to carry out the symbolic
gesture of burying their dead
and adorning grave sites with flowers.
Neanderthals may have also created
what may be the world's oldest cave art,
which was found in Spain.
Despite advances in their culture,
sometime after 40,000 years ago,
neanderthals mysteriously disappeared.
Some scientists believe the
neanderthals were killed
or out competed by modern
humans, or homo sapiens,
who arrived in Europe
at around the same time
as the neanderthals' extinction.
However, another theory suggests
that neanderthals mated with modern humans
and were absorbed into the
humans' much larger population.
That may explain why
most people of European
or Asian descent have 1%
to 2% neanderthal genes
in their DNA.
For more than 150 years, neanderthals
have perplexed anthropologists.
The first neanderthal fossil specimen
was discovered in Belgium in 1829
by Philippe-Charles Schmerling.
However, it wasn't officially classified
as neanderthal until decades later.
The first fossil to be
recognized as neandertahl
and as an early human or genus homo fossil
was found in 1856 by quarrymen in Germany.
The new species was named neanderthalensis
after the area where the fossils
were found, Neander Valley.
Neanderthals' fossils tell
us how evolution built them
to be sturdy, to survive
their harsh environment,
but their tools, art, and DNA tell us
that their resilience
also involved innovation,
creativity, and social behavior,
much like homo sapiens today.